Chris waters here with a gamespot news  update Sega is closing its San Francisco  office putting 300 jobs at risk Sega  issued a notice to investors on Friday  explaining that it expects to make just  34 million dollars in net profit by the  end of the fiscal year which is a real  garbage year compared to the 260 million  it made the year prior around 300 staff  are scheduled to be made redundant while  Sega's San Francisco office will be  relocated likely by summer to Southern  California everyone remembers Sega's  shift for making consoles to focusing on  games and now they're shifting away from  console game development as well to  focus on smart phone and PC online  gaming Sega's key releases of 2014 where  alien isolation rome 2 total war and  sonic boom another day another further  diminished possibility of Shenmue 3 this  is a developing story and we'll be  keeping you updated at gamespot.com /  news